How do we go about putting this in perspective?
Well, this has never happened before.
Babe Ruth never got the opportunity to do quite what Ohtani's doing this year,...
...but no one has ever done this.
This is an unprecedented season.
The most incredible season you could make a case than anyone's ever had,...
...given he's made the all-star team as a pitcher and a hitter...
...and the way he scored from second base the other day on the line,...
...drive single to right was ridiculous.
He is the greatest thing I've seen in baseball,...
...and I played a long time, but yeah.
I don't understand how you could be that good on both sides of the ball.
Let's just start there.
But it's not just the numbers.
It's what he is able to do on the field...
...that just makes no sense like inside-outing a ball, right?
Normally, you carve it inside,  you maybe slice it over the shortstop.
He's able to lean back and hit it for power in the opposite field.
That's a defensive swing.
That's a swing that you do like two strikes and try to slap it out of the glove...
...and he does everything with power.
So, you combine that with the fact that "Oh, he can throw 100 miles an hour...
...and strike out major league hitters at that level."
I've never seen anything like that.